sport donc football les sélectionnés
retenu par henri michel pour le premier
match international de l'équipe de
france cette saison un match amical
contre la tchécoslovaquie mercredi
prochain se sont retrouvés ce matin au
centre technique national de
clairefontaine
une ombre plane sur cette mise au vert
celle d'eric cantona l'attaquant de l'om
qui n'ont retenu en équipe aa hier soir
lens est vraiment à la hussarde une
véritable déclaration de guerre au
sélectionneur
écoutez cantona je dis tout simplement
que j'ai prouvé qu'ils pouvaient fondé
quelques espoirs mois et que s'il
pensait que j'étais à mes formes où il
ne fait pas les déclarations de la fête
où il averti où il discute avec moi il
n'a pas fait les unes plus de micro
puisque c'est une laque j'adore qui
disait que celui qui s'occupait des
oscars à hollywood la et et un sac à
merde dans ce cas est missionnée par une
rage difficilement contenue et des
déclarations fracassantes de cantona
après son excellent match contre
strasbourg hier soir il a même marqué un
but et il estime avoir prouvé ainsi à
henri michel qu'il méritait un peu plus
d'attention
cela dit dans leur forme les propos
d'eric cantona sont insultants pour le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
tristesse oui parce que je pense que
c'est c'est de ne pas désagréable mais
je crois aussi que c'est grave de porter
atteinte et des jugements tels que tel
que cela c'est ce que je regrette le
plus coté fédération le président
fournée paillard a jugé les propos de
cantona indigne d'un professionnel
sanction immédiate cantona ne sera même
pas du voyage en tchécoslovaquie avec
l'équipe espoirs comme initialement
prévu
après cinq sélections en équipe de
france à cantona envisage de rejouer
avec les bleus seulement lorsque michel
sera parti le sélectionneur français lui
ne voit pas l'avenir de manière aussi
catégorique et au delà de ma propre
personne je crois qu'il ya qu'à
l'intérêt du football et c'est
m'intéresse du football
de l'équipe de france est que cantona
sera présent avec avec je pense qu'il
faut il faut il parvenir je crois que
quand j'aurai une explication franche et
loyale et en tête à tête avec avec
entonnant les choses sont beaucoup plus
claires car pour l'instant tout le petit
monde du foot est en ébullition la
rencontre entre jean fournet-fayard
henri michel et cantona devrait avoir
lieu au plus vite d'ici là la sphère
sera le sujet de toutes les
conversations mais jamais devant une
caméra
dernière question une opinion sur la
sphère cantona ne convainquent